có bộ tại chính về tình hình phân bộ và giải ngân kể hoạt đầu tư công năm 2020.
Cô hội đá phân bộ và thuộc tưởng chính phủ rao cho các bộ.
Cơ có trung gân và địa phương tổng kể hoạt bộ n hơn một chiều tì đồng trong tổn sống này
còn hơn 30,000 chiến phẩy muốn nghiên tỷ đồng thuật thậm quyền phân bộ của chính phủ.
Đến hết thằng sau năm 2020, các bộ có trung gần bộ chỉ tiếp gần một chiều tì đồng cho răng bộ
nhận vụ giữ an.
Nếu không tính phần bộn cân đối nân xác địa phương rao tăng hơn 1,000 phẩy bẩy gần.
Cơ đủ điều két bụ chi bốn trong đó khoảng 30 phẩy tăng nghi tỷ đồng là vốn
tức hiện các trường chính bộ tío cũng ra mới được ra bộ sung và giữa thằng sau.
Bây giờ các đỏ một số bộ ngành địa phương để sốt điều trình giảng kể hoạt bộn
gió không còn điều câu xe giục để điều trình cho đơn vị khác.
Về dành lên tình đến hét ngày bảo mấy thằng sau, cả nước đã dành gần bà trong năm 2020
điên tỷ đồng.
Đặt 30 phẩy năm 2020 kể hoạt thu tưởng chỉ phủ rao.
Sốt không kì năm ngoài hành gì cũng trong hàng bâm.
Sốt vốn giảnh nân tăng hơn 30 phẩy bán nghe tỷ đồng và giảnh chỉ trình đối.
Nhưng tỷ lệ giảnh nân thấp hơn khó phẩy năm 2020.